he's a Brazilian mixed martial artist
and former UFC middleweight champion he
holds the longest title defense streak
in UFC history with 16 consecutive wins
and 10 title defenses UFC president Dana
White and other experts have called him
the greatest mixed martial artist of all
time
he's Anderson Silva and here his top 10
rules for success I love my my sport I
love my job and I straight my fault was
all the time in my life for training
because white is my life and sometimes
everything's changed because you have
the good working bad working and good
experience by experience but I love my
job and I talked to my family and I said
I go back to fight because this is me
number one
the CDO for mid-tempo spaces are some
convinced either only during the season
opening things women to damage a meager
total anything total unity momentum eyes
no momentum as code or opioid want
the ride hurts him boom the knee to the
head hurts him another name that right
knee caught him flush go that was it we
kissed a great fight need fight for the
for a long time and in the same category
so I go training hard because all the
fighters when I go to FC is the best
fighters in the world know me no need
all the fighters I need you train it
hard because when they go or when I when
I start the fight
Nick have good training have good Jersey
to have a good boxing and is the fight
is the great fight all the people in the
world waiting for this and I'm prepared
for this I go for fight for Nick because
his technique Nick his danger and the
same position making the fight for a
long time I know fight for a long time I
think is the great fight
Aniston holding onto the arm he takes
him down swarms up
so I'm very happy because my family
giving the support and help me for back
because my sons and my wife say that
this is your time this is your life go
going
to finish the fight where some of the
best if not the best I've ever seen in
MMA
urban throws the kick intercept a visit
right on the chin takes him down it
looked like urban was done already from
that one punch and just a few punches
more and that's it I remember the my
life and start the training and the more
difficult is the training because my
stepmom see me know martial art oh
because this is danger do I need you
pick it up your focus for school and the
same professional your dad your brothers
my family and Brazil or my old family my
brothers my dad is co-op in Brazil so
and I talked to my dad no I don't go for
for for school for the Academy for cop I
go for training because I love martial
arts my dad and my mom say you crazy why
that's funny
your brother's your dad is the cop where
you go change because why why is your
problem I say mom dad this is my dream
so now it's very good it worked out it
seems yeah work that it seemed to worked
out for everybody yeah my dad talked to
me now my stepdad taught me now oh good
job and we were so wrong
Scottie was
he gave Chris every chance he possibly
could to recover and that is the end if
Ali Khan's mystery not do what is the
thing there to evoke our football was it
they had okay I see Kansai TV on Jesus
Tejano forget about the no 2 percent
solution why should you need to come
where certain office in jihad and it's a
given mass quizzes as Christ was FISA
had my cohesion my Steve McQueen
Newmark's aficionado get a page that a
simple sent to focus disguises key
supposed to make vulture frittata into
the trend for a trend break evil psycho
Seagal Eli for success in film a fate
seem to be damaged
Anderson
Franklin
that shot right there broke Rich's bills
and that was the end of the fight high
kick another high kick to the body tried
the big elbow builder me right to the
head and rich goes down for the last
time here
John the Karthik Sanda Oh mush on the
face for that right knee
staggers back I don't know I don't know
sometimes I I think in my mind so when I
stop Anderson I talked to my master it
was my first master and why why is the
time for you to stop master my message
saying you not have time for stop you
time in new heart when you [ __ ] say no
more no more because when you come to
here is young I trained you know for
fight by training for life in martial
arts change your life you wasn't using
my technique and more martial arts for
fight but I know show you for fight I
show you for you life and I think this
when I finish my heart giving the sport
for say Anderson
he's out
and here we see complete disdain for the
striking ability of forests look at that
right hand look at that I mean that was
just like a paw when I'd I find the
first fighting with C and when I like I
like I got the belt I stand the belt for
seven years now is no new one for me so
I'm working for with C do C is my family
so my focus now is the fight for Nick
Diaz when I finish the fight for Nick
I'm will I go training for next fight
this was one of the most amazing look at
this he throws it from here watch this
Oh beautiful
no a simple teammate put K and we
Sportage compact was the most partisan
key geometers quizzes new strands kiss
contesting quizzes stone bow but the
stinky episode qaboos mosque on with
gunship on but to pull to mama cat they
had become a mosque on the brass Timon
soku it had to know suka had my second
peg on tsukumo Bert I didn't tell you
was I chosen conseguí Trina my setting
surface tension tempo he you his karma
our conversation tonight
porque Sundays at let the supertrain
atomize with my or eternity me adieu GG
total fiscal so volatile made us to me
the truth
and who says Payton tokenization Tamara
yes the finding a door
that was that was a lack out possible
when you go to fight this you know how
people who have fans
I have nothing when you go inside the
corner you need you take it off all the
people in and close together you and go
inside and put in your mind in your
heart for fight and it's good sometimes
I have the bad manners good Danish but
some the more important is you happy
when you go to fight you go to walking
for October you happy everything is good
we said second-to-none
to the face thank you so much for
watching I made this video because Jeff
Liang Zhou Ming asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do
I'd also love to know which of Anderson
Silva's top ten rules meant the most to
you leave it in the comments I'll join
the discussion thank you so much for
watching
you seem to believe and I'll see you
soon